今日はこちらスピーカー付んです相変わらず言葉の勉強について話ししたいんです
特に今日は英語の勉強について
んんん
5分
うん
まずこの僕のビデオをしキーであればぜひ登録してください
そしてこの金のところにキックすれば新しいビデオが
その手でた時に
通知します
そしてまあ私今入らない言語を勉強しているリンクのところでも是非皆さん参加して
ください
木刀な需要に新しい外国語英語だけじゃなくてそこで勉強できますけれどもそれではね
モードボール聞いたことありますか m
オーディ alo aro
モードガールというのはそれ私もですね
いろんな言葉を勉強した時でもその証言は
あの技術用語というかですねもう聞いたこともうなかったんですけれども
あの今のそのリンクも作った時に色々とこ
言葉のそういう
勉強に関するいろんな本も買って猛勉強その研究したわけですよ
でそこまでが僕は木材の業かだったんですけども
それでこういう佐野英語の文法についての音も買ったんですけれどもそのだけにもう
ローバーブスというらが非常に大切みたい
いいな部分なんですよね
このこの本だと50ページくらいあるんですよモールフープ51ロール web パイプ
でモールフルーツの外にはですねー
一応
可能性がねだから100%
今よ可能性がある義務がある
所で不安定さがあるそれを表現するのはモールこういう同士なんですよねしかしこの
概念が
必要かどうかあるいは処理をうまく使うためにですねこれだけ50ページの説明を読む
必要があるか僕非常に疑問に思えます
日本語の場合はやるはずやるべきやん神しれないやらなければならない
それをですねやはりをの後の
を少しずつ私は慣れてきたわけですよ
英語でこういうことを日本語でこういうふうに言いました
そして何回も聞いて読んで場合によって使って前によって間違って使って結果的に少し
ずつ
こういう言葉の使い方に
まあ慣れてくるわけですよ
だからそのうえでそれだけの言葉についての豊富な経験がある上でまぁ説明を見たり
住むも役に立つ参考になるかもしれないけれども
まずそれだけの全体的なレベルアップがないと
ただ単にこのモードブログに集中して勉強しようと思えばそういうほど
参考にならないだから逆に言うともうだーグロービスをうまく使おうためにはモールを
グロスを勉強しない方がいい
んですそれよりもあのたくさん聴いたりたくさん読んだり
その新しい今エイブな英語のその新しい炭素の言語のいろんなパターンに慣れてきた方
がいい
そり早く慣れるまでにはたくさん聞いたり読んだりするしかないです
だから
こちらで書いてあるような
だからまあ英語で言うとね50万円正サーフハープまーすあー2 f 2ポーズ2
11勉強しても萌えならないんですよ
これは曲数も難しいんですよねあるいは何ですか
degree セフティプレゼンタイムパスタールティンプーローラーズそれをですね
少しずつ慣れてくるしかないんです
いい処理を
勉強して処理からテストして何もならないんですよね
だから
旦那来たでも
まず我慢強くたくさんできれば面白い内容のものをたくさん聞いて読んで場合によって
使って間違って使ったり
もう一度使ってみたりそういう家庭なんですよでモールガールズにその
早くましたしようと思えば多分無理だと思います
まあそういうことでさよならいい
うん
5分